[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il a c'est quoi son coup de
gueule parler lui parler lui bien parce
que froid il n'est pas bien alors qu'est
ce qu'il a c'est vrai d'ailleurs on a
écrit mon coup de gueule là dessus c'est
très gentil de la part de production
mais j'ai pas besoin de l'écrire
voilà j'ai parlé avec le wave ou déchiré
mon cas vous n'avez à déchirer ses
traits comme 21 allée hier honnêtement
et franchement je n'ai pas dormi de la
nuit
canon je vous promets c'est vrai nous
avons marqué pas tout merci oui ne lui
paraissait pas t'en sortir hier ce qui
s'est passé toutes les missions ça a été
pour moi le tpm paix de l'humiliation de
la première minute à la dernière d'abord
on a commencé par un tube non non non
[Applaudissements]
viande bio c'est ça le dérange pas du
tout hier pour une foire n'a pas d'un
sujet important la politique ça a duré
15 minutes pendant 15 minutes
là bas moi j'ai levé la main pendant 15
minutes vous m'avez regarder pendant ces
15 minutes
et à chaque fois jamais jamais une fois
vous me donnez la parole et pendant les
quinze minutes voyaient dans vos yeux
t'es gentil la [ __ ] au bout tu es
mignonne quand on voudra ton avis sur la
couleur de cheveux d'eve angeli ou pour
pas une musculation on t'appellera mais
quand on parle de politique ou de choses
un peu importante classe et la
discussion entre grands on parle pas
avec toi alors que moi et mes même
regard des messages en a pas maintenant
tout à l'heure on déconne ravec toile
moi la politique c'est de la passion va
la table des petits lots